[Aplausos]
[Música]
la historia que quiero contarles hoy día
es la historia de miles de personas que
viven en comunidades de las zonas
rurales de la provincia de loja al sur
del ecuador
y también representa la vida o la
historia de vida de millones de personas
que viven en nuestro continente
y también es una historia personal
porque me cambió la forma de ver la
educación superior y cuestionarme acaso
desde las universidades no deberíamos
empezar a pensar de una manera distinta
en la que
la multidisciplinaridad sea la base para
el diseño de las carreras y posgrados
y vayamos más allá más allá de esa
tradición a la organización del
conocimiento que muchos ya la declaran
como cauca
en el 2004
y tuve la oportunidad de empezar a
trabajar en lo que es ahora uno de los
centros
de la puse más grandes de investigación
el centro de investigación para la salud
en américa latina'
desde entonces fui parte de un equipo de
investigación que quería entender lo que
estaba pasando con un mal de chávez con
una enfermedad desatendida
y para poder controlarla y poder
prevenir y poder beneficiará a miles de
personas de estas comunidades tuve la
oportunidad de irme a muchas comunidades
de la costa de la sierra el oriente de
nuestro país y entender cómo vivía la
gente
y siempre tuve la oportunidad de llevar
mi cámara
porque dicho sea de paso la fotografía
es una pasión que han usado mi vida
desde desde que hice mi tesis de energía
allá por los años 90
entonces conocí a la gente de estas
comunidades principalmente nos enfocamos
en la provincia de loja
sus culturas sus celebridades sus
celebraciones
aprendí que poco a poco se está
perdiendo actividades como los telares
porque a los jóvenes no están
interesados en hacer esto
con mucha panela con maní
y también entendí que es una zona rica
en biodiversidad
registramos como unas 80 especies de
aves en la zona donde hemos trabajado
pero también tuve la oportunidad
de documentar fotográficamente y vivir
las limitaciones
las limitaciones que estas poblaciones
y que vivían en condiciones desatendidas
la organización mundial de la salud
reconoce a un grupo de más de 20
enfermedades tropicales desatendidas
qué afecta a miles de millones de
personas en 149 países de nuestro
planeta
y afecta a aquellas personas que viven
con un poquito más
de un dólar día
la enfermedad de chagas es una de ellas
una de esas enfermedades tropicales
desatendidas
afecta en américa en solamente nuestro
continente afecta entre 7 a 8 millones
de personas desde el sur de estados
unidos hasta argentina
alguien conoce el que le aprovecha gas
hacia la mano por favor
algunos trabajan conmigo
no se vale
en ecuador se estima según estudios que
alrededor de unas 200.000 personas
estarían infectadas
42 millones en riesgo principalmente
aquellas que viven en las zonas rurales
desatendidas bajo los 2 mil metros de
altitud
y en loja en la provincia de loja
alrededor de 197 mil personas estarían
en estas zonas en riesgo
pero qué es la enfermedad sachs
chagas es el apellido de carlos chagas
un médico brasileño de inicios del siglo
pasado
descubrió y caracterizó esta enfermedad
porque la gente se estaba muriendo en
las comunidades donde están haciendo el
ferrocarril
y fue enviado por el ministerio de salud
para entender está
esta enfermedad de hecho fue enviado
para tratar a las personas que estaban
con malaria pero se dio cuenta que
habían estos insectos en las viviendas
la enfermedad de chagas no tiene vacuna
y su tratamiento tiene efectos
colaterales muy fuertes para los
pacientes
sea
ponemos nuestros ojos del microscopio en
una gota de sangre podemos ver
el trypanosoma cruzi que es un parásito
unicelular una sola célula
que está en la sangre ahí uno puede ver
los glóbulos rojos representados en esos
círculos rojos
y ese parásito puede vivir en la sangre
de estos mamíferos mamíferos pequeños
como la ardilla que hay muchas en loja
y existen estos bichos de estos insectos
que solamente se alimentan de sangre
y cuando chupo en la sangre al mamífero
se contagian se infectan los insectos y
pueden transmitir a otro mamífero pero
qué pasa cuando el ser humano va a las
zonas boscosas fragmenta el bosque
coloniza al insecto le da igual
alimentarse de la sangre de una ardilla
o de un ser humano
a continuación quiero
mostrarles unos testimonios sobre el mal
de chagas que hemos que hemos tenido en
la provincia aloja
antes de eso quiero comentarle sobre
transmisión cuando el insecto nos pica
están adaptados fisiológicamente para
edificar enseguida justo al lado de la
picadura la picadura no es la que
transmite la enfermedad
es cuando uno se rasca
y eso mecánicamente uno ingresa ese
cóctel de parásitos que están en las
heces de estos insectos si está
infectado claro
y empieza la infección
en tu cuerpo te puede dar dolor de
cabeza fiebre tengo 23 días te pasa
pero qué pasa cuando
y además el sistema inmune en este
parásito
se acumula
y migra al corazón al esófago o al
intestino y puede causar la muerte
imagínense una persona de cinco años en
una comodidad rural
es infectado a los 5 años a mis 25 años
tengo 23 hijos
imagínense la carga yo ya no puedo
trabajar porque mi corazón no me permite
le bombea bien
por eso es que la enfermedad de chagas
también es conocida como una enfermedad
silenciosa porque después de 15 a 20
años aparecen los síntomas
y también es reconocida por una de las
enfermedades con mayor carga económica
en las economías en desarrollo
a continuación los testimonios
realizados por un equipo que conforme de
que ir a la universidad
más
[Música]
sería un vídeo hecho tintos así de este
por tito pero por pagar sangre para ver
si quiero unos días chinchón se come una
media botella de sangre
ese día primero estábamos del mismo
levantó cuando eran tres estaban días
andando por la cama entonces yo les digo
admitiendo aquí hago esto y le digo mi
nivel que es dice chinchorros dicen
matan
y yo tuve miedo intento me entrevisté
esos animales entonces dice digo más
miedo este tu mano y también no es tumba
y cuando ya lo tumba se le sube uno y mi
abuelita también falleció y como el
doctor mario de 7
que eso se hace crece el corazón que los
órganos mi abuelita también tuvo el
problema de que ya tenía el corazón
demasiado grande
[Música]
con tejas las paredes de barro otras
veces tablas o tres palitos
la otra es de boda
los chinitos que siempre meditamos una
cocina
y hasta bocas
[Música]
y miles de niños en la provincia de loja
están expuestos a condiciones en las que
esos bienes están infectadas por estos
insectos chinchorros
cuando empecé a trabajar en el 2004 en
este centro de investigación para
sudamérica latina
apenas conocía sobre este insecto en las
clases de biología de entomología me
enseñó el profesor que habían estos
insectos que solamente se alimentaban de
sangre
y qué
podían transmitir una enfermedad
también pues que podría transmitirse a
través de las transfusiones sanguíneas
de madre del feto a través del brazo
y también ahora se ha descubierto que se
puede ser ser transmitido a través de
oralmente cuando uno ingiere alimentos
y contaminados con las heces de estos
insectos pero es muy muy poco probable
el problema en nuestro país es la
transmisión a través del insecto a
través de las veces
en el 2004 aprendí entonces no solamente
los insectos de la transmisión sino
también de las condiciones de vida en
las que vivían las personas en estas
comunidades
y puedo decir que el pueblo lojano es
uno de los pueblos más amables
hemos visitado miles de casas en cientos
de comunidades y siempre había una
persona que nos brinde un vaso de agua
una panela un pan
o una fruta
hicimos encuestas de vivienda para
entender la tipología de las viviendas y
los factores de riesgo
buscamos conjunto en colaboración con
personal del ministerio de salud pública
los chinchorros dentro y fuera de la
vivienda
hicimos campañas educativas
si encontramos chinchorros pues
procederemos a rociar y entendimos cómo
era la tradicional casa a lohan a tenían
las condiciones perfectas para que estos
insectos detrás de los nidos de ardillas
vuelen y se infecte en las casas y de
noche puedan chupar la sangre en los
habitantes
entendimos que las casas están dispersas
hay un dicho que me encanta
cuando uno le pregunta dónde está la
siguiente casa del vecino es requisito
no más éxito nuevas está en la otra loma
a dos horas de distancia
la primera vez que fui era como haber
ido al siglo 16 transportando
transportar en el tiempo
por qué
me recordó mucho al realismo mágico de
la novela mejor que casa
porque estas personas todavía vive en
una economía de consumo
y trabajan la tierra ajena como si fuera
propia a cambio de diezmos agrarios
hasta ahí llegaba a nuestro alcance
disciplinario desde la biología para
entender el mal de chagas pero teníamos
que tener un enfoque distinto es por eso
que diseñamos una estrategia llamada
hogares saludables para vivir saludable
en conjunto
en colaboración con arquitectos
sociólogos comunicadores
diseñamos participas y
participativamente una a una casa
respetando la forma de vida local no
solamente ir a construir una casa con
cuatro paredes sino entender el uso de
espacio respetando la forma de vida de
las personas
y con acompañamiento antes durante
después capacitamos a los miembros de la
comunidad en temas de construcción en
tierra y pasar de esto
a esto
2012-2018
el chagas es un ejemplo que ilustra cómo
debemos rebasar esas fronteras de las
disciplinas carlos morín filósofo
francés contemporáneo ya advierte
declara en su ensayo el pensamiento
complejo
que esta organización del conocimiento
está de alguna forma caduca y declara y
dice que la inteligencia padece de
ceguera
para controlar chagas necesitamos de la
ayuda de muchas personas muchas
disciplinas médicos arquitectos
economistas abogados
y claro también de la comunidad
desde la biología puede entender los
factores ambientales ecológicos de esta
enfermedad desde las ciencias sociales
puede entender los factores o
determinantes
económicos políticos geográficos
y desde la fotografía me dio la
sensibilidad
para usar como una herramienta para la
investigación
y también como una herramienta poderosa
para unir dos mundos con desconectados
la academia y la comunidad por eso
conforme un equipo de trabajo
multidisciplinario
por el momento somos cinco comunicadores
biólogos videógrafos fotógrafos
pero con una pasión enlazar la ciencia
con la comunidad y con un efecto
transformador
yo pienso que
en este proyecto este equipo representa
lo que podría ser la nueva universidad
investigadores estudiantes de pregrado
posgrado fuera de las aulas y
laboratorios
encontrar sus pasiones sus talentos para
que puedan hacer proyectos
multidisciplinarios
con un efecto transformador
tengo quiero finalizar con dos mensajes
uno para las autoridades de la educación
rompamos esas fronteras de las
disciplinas para crear una
transformación en la educación y para
los jóvenes no se olviden de sus
pasiones cultiven las amenas tal vez
algún día puede hacer ese ingrediente
esencial en la gran receta de esos
vídeos
[Aplausos]
[Música]